all right so i want to talk about your
show cause i know you want to talk about
your show it's fantastic care less no
only murders in the building it's why is
murder funny and it is so funny in your
show because it seems like it wouldn't
be because it's murder well you know
there's a huge history of crime
going back even before this this show i
mean it goes back you know
i mean even costello movies were about
you know somebody getting murdered by a
frankenstein you know and and and
there's so many podcasts about murder
right and that's what i think is
interesting about the show that it
combines the obsession with crime and
murder and podcast well you know the
show actually came up like like two two
years ago and then podcasts in that
interim grew and the podcast was always
a bit a part of it and now we're sort of
writing a wave of podcast delight what
do you
what do you make of that i i don't
understand how people under 40
it seems like their attention span is
either three seconds or four hours
i can tell you why
because the podcasts go on too long for
me
well i can tell you
it's podcasts are perfect for doing two
things at once
yes for example i have a bicycle an
exercise and have a podcast so i'm doing
two things at once but if i were going
to sit and listen to a podcast i i
wouldn't be able to do it and what do
you think about it and also you know you
listen to a podcast while you're talking
to your child
[Laughter]
[Applause]
or when i'm talking to marty you know i
say marty wants to say something i put
in
the podcast
let's talk generations because your
co-star and this is selena gomez who's
fantastic yes i know
do you know her music yes absolutely i
want to love you like a love song baby
one of my i mean i'm always looking for
new music that sounds like it could have
been a hit in any decade
that's one that's a great record well
she's so good in the show too she's
fantastic and we get along great she's a
great actress and
she puts out our pills in the morning
yeah
nice
she didn't make a big quote by the first
day of shooting she went into st you
know i i don't know if she knew she came
and said i'm such a big fan judy dench
she said so
[Applause]
yeah but i mean i love the dynamic that
a millennial and two boomers because
these two generations always seem to be
feuding somehow the gen x which are in
the middle they get a pass on this but
the boomers are always hearing it from
the millennials that we ruined the world
we took all the jobs hasn't it always
been that way i mean in the 60s you know
you were talking about doing the
smothers brothers show here oh that's
right this studio no it wasn't this
studio this is carol burnett
not the same studio smothers brothers
across the way that's why my heart broke
when i came in because they're on they
said they're on the smothers brothers
stage that's the carol burnett stage
anyway
no when i first started writing here i
was 21 years old wow and uh the reason i
got hired at 21 years old because the
the mantra of the day was never trust
anyone over 30. so they wanted young
writers and you know the the writers
they had were great they wrote for jack
benny and of course they looked at us
sideways you know these kids coming in
and uh but you know they were tolerant
they're and they were great writers and
and that show i don't know if did do you
remember the smothers brothers show
anybody in this oh okay great it should
be it's i mean they should have a legacy
greater than they have they it was only
funny but it really kind of changed the
discourse
absolutely in this country so okay so i
want to ask about ageism because you
guys are old and i'm old and
you know it it pisses me off that this
is the last acceptable prejudice you
know people can always say they don't
like anything you do well you're old
are you saying that because i'm starting
to look like the guy from up
no you
it's the glasses
no no it starts with the glasses i got
new frames and i realized as i was about
to walk out here i looked like this as
in so many things you were so ahead of
your time and prescient
cause you because you had the white hair
when you were three so yeah now you
never really i never thought of dyeing
my hair once you still look so glad you
look like steve martin yeah
like he always looked yeah that's that's
a trick
do you think i look like him ish
but do you think we should lean in i
mean to me the only answer because we're
not getting younger yeah is to lean into
it you know kids you know when they
that's where they attacked me you're old
and i'm like yeah but you're stupid
maybe
maybe that's why i know some [ __ ] and
you and you don't you know it's like us
backstage yeah
no i i think you're absolutely right i
don't think you try to hide anything
first of all you can't and you should
then why did you go into makeup
because
because i
on the way here i had smiled in a hunk
of stuff i put on it fell off and i
caught it and they had to patch it up
but that's not the point
you